deutsche und Autos dazu habe ich
einen kleinen Text geschrieben den
ich Ihnen an der Stelle Vorlesen
möchte der Text trägt den Titel
joy of driving
oder zu deutsch Fahrvergnügen ein Wort das
man übrigens auch im amerikanischen kennt
so wie andere deutsche Worte das können sie
weltschmerzzeitgeist Blitzkrieg Fahrvergnügen
Amerika mag das Land der unbegrenzten
Möglichkeiten sein die unbegrenzte
Möglichkeit schnell Auto zu fahren gehört
definitiv nicht dazu selbst auf einem Top
ausgebauten Highway davon mit nur maximal 70 miles
per AUA entlang zu tun aber alle halten sich daran
ich habe mich immer gewundert warum bis ich
einmal wegen zu hoher Geschwindigkeit von der
Highway Patrol angehalten wurde als hinter
mir das schwarz-weiße Auto mit der Sirene
auftauchte fühlte ich mich augenblicklich in
den Film No Country for Old Men zurückversetzt
spielt dort eine psychopathischen Serienkiller
der als Kopf verkleidet einem artlosen
Autofahrer ein Bolzenschussgerät
an die Stirn setzt und abdrückt
die Ironie an der Geschichte jeder police
officer der sie irgendwo in der Pampa anhält
kennt natürlich ebenfalls diesen Film und weiß
welche Todesängste sie gerade ausstehen ich
möchte nicht ins Detail gehen aber nach diesem
Ereignis bin ich nie wieder zu schnell gefahren
für Amerikaner sind Autos in erster Linie
Gebrauchsgegenstände deswegen hat drüben
auch keiner ein Problem seinen Wagen an Freunde
zu verleihen ein deutscher würde wahrscheinlich
eher seine eigene Frau verleihen denn das Auto ist
uns heilig mein Vater zum Beispiel käme niemals
auf die Idee in seinem Wagen zu Essen selbst
wenn er fünf Tage in einer Vollsperrung stünde
Essen im Auto ist mein Vater Blasphemie heiraten
im Auto wäre irgendwie noch okay aber essen no way
noch schlimmer wäre für ihn nur noch im Auto
etwas zu trinken das muss er auch nicht denn
die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass er während der drei
minütigen Fahrt zu seinem Kegelclub plötzlich die
hydriert ist relativ gering in den USA dagegen
dient das Auto als eine Art erweiterter Wohnraum
man ist man trinkt man macht seine Steuererklärung
kriegt Kinder lässt sich scheiden man lebt quasi
in seinem Wagen weil die Entfernungen ebenso
riesig sind wenn sie mit dem Auto von New
York nach Los Angeles fahren dann wären sie laut
Google Maps 44 Stunden nonstop unterwegs wir sind
Frankfurt ins Auto steigen und losfahren dann
sind sie nach 44 Stunden kurz hinter Würzburg
das sind ganz andere Dimensionen
deshalb ist auch die erste Frage die an
Amerikaner beim Autokauf stellt wie viele
Becherhalter hat der Wagen Amerikaner sind
fasziniert von Becherhaltern vergessen Sie
unwichtige Details wie Seitenaufprallschutz
Bremsassistent oder ein Lenkrad nein sind die
Becherhalter die zählen als ich einmal einen
Dodge Caravan gemietet habe habe ich mir die
Mühe gemacht die Becherhalter in dem Wagen zu
zählen ich kam auf sage und schreibe 17 Stück für
maximal sieben Fahrgäste was zum Teufel macht dann
amerikanischer Insassen mit 2,43 Becherhaltern
ich bin mir sicher wenn die fahrzeugdesigner bei
Dodge irgendwann mal auf die Idee kommen in die
Hutablage auch noch einen pizzasteinofen
einzubauen kann die Konkurrenz einpacken
in Deutschland würde sich so ein Auto nie
durchsetzen mein Vater ist ja schon in seiner
Ehre gekränkt wenn er Automatik fahren
muss das selbstfahrende Auto ist für uns
Deutsche deswegen so unattraktiv weil wir selbst
entscheiden wollen gegen welchen Baum wir fahren
ich weiß ich weiß natürlich ist unsere
sprichwörtliche autoverrücktheit auch ein
bisschen in Klischee nicht jeder Deutsche ist
ein Auto nach aber jeder Amerikaner glaubt das
als wir nach New York eingereist
sind blickte mich der Grenzbeamte an
schaut in meinen Pass und sagte fröhlich hey Mann
blöderweise habe ich sein Spiel nicht
mitgespielt und geantwortet sorry
schlagartig verfinsterte sich seine Mine
you don't have a favorite so you can German
und dann baut er mich zu einem
kurzen Gespräch in den Nebenraum
etwa 45 Stunden lang und ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen vergessen Sie alles was
Sie jemals über Waterboarding gehört haben
im Endeffekt ist es gar nicht so schlimm
trotzdem an der Stelle ein kleiner Tipp
sollten Sie jemals von der border control
nach ihrer lieblingsautomarke gefragt
werden dann sagen sie meinetwegen einen
Fiat Cinquecento mit eingebauter
Mikrowelle und 53 Becherhaltern
das ist immer noch besser
als zu sagen interessiert
mich nicht oder noch schlimmer Porsche nein eleven
[Applaus]